our expedition takes us to a place man
has avoided for centuries the geological
mapping mission what our support cameras
way more dangerous than a gun
on Skull Island rated pg-13 experienced
at an IMAX much tensed this is a
satellite photo of an uncharted island
in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science meet
Kong has been rican sieved as a myth
come to life you came here looking for a
track at who or what am i tracking
the island isn't just a place that looks
specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators you
don't go into someone's house and start
dropping bombs unless you're picking a
fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission
I became they have he was my white whale
we're very happy to say that we have the
biggest Kong of them all
he is truly monstrous in size and scale
and scope when people step foot on this
island
the first visceral response is to look
at that thing and say that's a god
that's the big one
this film will be an immersive spectacle
calm skull island has things you haven't
seen before it takes you to a different
world where things are beautiful and
terrifying all at the same time
it's huge and we're talking about one of
the greatest myths of all time
you
you